when AMC's The Walking Dead first
premiered on Halloween night in 2010 it
felt as if the world stopped turning and
television lovers across the globe
turned into zombies themselves ones
hungry for more episodes of the
groundbreaking post-apocalyptic horror
series all anyone could chat about at
the work water cooler was what crazy
amazing or insane thing happened to Rick
Grimes the night before the gripping
action of the series adapted from the
popular comic books by Robert Kirkman
helped turn the Walking Dead into a must
watch right alongside prestige programs
like Breaking Bad and Mad Men in the
years since however things have taken a
drastic in disheartening turn the show
has never been an award season darling
but now ratings have started to slip as
viewers begin to tune out of the
sheriff's latest undead dramas so what
happened to make the Walking Dead lose
favor with fans let's take a look but as
always beware the spoilers squandered
characters The Walking Dead has had no
shortage of characters come and go but
there have been an unfortunate amount of
these newcomers who've walked away
completely underdeveloped or been
written out just as they got interesting
at the same time there are also plenty
of others who have been allowed to
linger for way too long
Beth Greene hung on long enough to
become a bunch of different people and
none all at once she started out as a
boring farm girl who didn't say much
then she became a caretaker to a corpse
which made her only slightly interesting
but then she got saddled with Daryl as
his new confidante slash badass roadie
pal soon after she was depicted as some
mini master of espionage during her
stint at the hospital and let's just say
the art was far from linear there's also
the matter of father Gabriel Stokes the
priest who seems to do little more than
sit on a high horse and repeatedly
backstab his brethren he might have
served a purpose in early seasons but
like Beth the writers seemed to struggle
with what to do with him
then there are characters who are
interesting but get taken out far too
soon like t-dog Noah and dr. Denis
they're demises leave little impact on
viewers because we have in time to care
about them if you don't wait
meanwhile the loss of those who've
overstayed their welcome can bring a
sense of relief rather than sadness in
other words the show has had a hard time
making fans even care about its most
dramatic moments anymore which means
they've had to resort to cheap mind
games to keep people interested getting
whiplash to help increase the show's
hype the series has intentionally
tricked its audience in rather
infuriating ways in season 6 the
creatives crafted a plot purposely meant
to trick everyone into believing that
Glyn had been eaten alive by zombies
using sneaky camera angles and close-up
shots the show made it appear as though
Glenn's guts really were getting pulled
out of his body as he screamed in agony
in reality though it was a corpse whose
insides were spilling everywhere and
Flynn was just mirrored after a few
episodes it was revealed that he easily
escaped that brush with the beyond but
the gotcha moment was seen as a cheap
trick and part of a growing troupe of TV
characters who've been killed off only
to miraculously return within the span
of a few episodes the showrunners didn't
learn their lesson there either
something similar happened in the
penultimate episode of season six when
daryl is shot and blood speckles the
screen of course it was all just
deliberate misdirection then The Walking
Dead pulled one over on viewers the very
next episode by showing negan smashing
someone's skull in but not revealing who
it was viewers were left to spend all
summer debating who was on the receiving
end based on the camera angles the
comics version of the scene casting
calls from the set and more and then
when the answer was revealed well it was
even crueler than anyone could have
expected meeting Lucille fans familiar
with Robert Kirkman's comics were
equally excited and nervous about
negan's arrival at the tail end of
season six Jeffrey Dean Morgan was a
spot-on casting choice in his ability to
sling four-letter words and his trusty
barbed bat Lucille were second to none
but his arrival also meant that some fan
favorite characters were about to get
the axe and when the seventh season
returned in the fall of 2016 that's
exactly what happened
but even though fans were fully braced
for carnage well the site of it plain
out on screen was still too much for
some audiences to take in addition to
taking out fan favorite Glen reek
after having just given him a mulligan
at life a few episodes before Meegan's
bat also laid waste to fan favorite
Abraham as well both lanes were built of
equal
tality in disregard for the
sensitivities of their friends and
family or the audience's at home viewers
who'd already been on the fence about
sticking with the series used this
opportunity to call it quits for good
inciting the excess violence and dislike
for negan among other complaints for a
show that was built on gore this single
scene seemed to be simply too much for
its fanbase to bear and they were
probably right to tune out at that point
of premise considering what would come
next part of darkness The Walking Dead
has always hit hard with misery gore and
all things grim and that's to be
expected from a series of its genre
sliced up limbs open wounds decomposing
corpses blood and guts are the stock
stuff of a post-apocalyptic horror show
violence and viscera are just the name
of the game but after negan and his not
so merry band of saviors came to town
The Walking Dead experienced a dramatic
shift in tone no longer did it feel like
a cautionary tale a series exploring the
intricacies of existence in the darkness
of human nature it became something that
takes pleasure in causing pain
transforming into physical and emotional
torture sure brutality can be brushed
aside when it's justified and balanced
with some beautiful moments but when an
already dark series zeroes in on just
how sociopathic its central villain is
the cynical attitude and malevolent tone
can be too much to take losing focus one
of the biggest problems with the Walking
Dead now is that despite the show's
title there's very little focus on the
undead anymore Michonne's badass samurai
slayings and shots of Daryl's innovative
maiming tactics have been reduced
significantly
instead the show spins in an ordinate
amount of time with the characters
talking about their feelings and plans
to take out other humans in its infancy
the series was the pinnacle of what
post-apocalyptic storytelling should
look and feel like and there was a clear
central focus Rick and the gang need to
outsmart the zombies and survive long
enough to see a world without them
roaming about and they would sacrifice
things they love to accomplish that now
the crew is almost exclusively
threatened by insane human villains in
the premise that the show wants held
fighting the titular Walking Dead has
all but vanished meanwhile the show has
also had a hard time keeping things
fresh from season to season in the
beginning the creatives weren't afraid
to branch out and make up their own
characters to spice things up consider
the fact that Daryl and his brother
Merle weren't even part of Robert
Kirkman's comics and yet they were among
the most interesting characters to ever
grace the show now it
though the series seems to be simply
cycling through the villains and major
Wars contained in the comics and even
those creative liberties they do take
tend to be a bit formulaic most fans can
probably predict what each will do and
how each episode will play out Rick
Grimes will lead his people to some kind
of temporary safety but then all hell
will break loose someone will get
attacked or go haywire and pass away the
group will mourn and move on but then
the same thing will happen at their next
hideout rinse and repeat
fans can only be expected to endure that
kind of repetition for so long tough
competition when the Walking Dead first
debuted it was one of a kind in ushering
in the zombie craze
since then though even devout Walking
Dead fans have turned to other programs
to get their undead fill shows like The
CW's iZombie and sci-fi Z nation are
having a markedly better time because
they've opted not to go to grim the way
The Walking Dead has zombies are
supposed to be at least a little fun
when they're not completely frightening
but the Walking Dead has always been
more about emotionally affecting drama
than the more lighthearted or
action-oriented entries in the genre a
better balance of moods could have gone
a long way toward hanging on to the
longtime fans who stopped watching but
eight seasons in the show is as dark and
dreary as it's ever been and some fans
have just had enough thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]